-Uh, Alicia,
you're from Sweden.
And every time
you come on the show,
you introduce me to
a Swedish game.
You've brought
a new one tonight.
-Mm-hmm.
-I heard you say it earlier.
It is called
Urlandstik joolafton
-What?
[ Laughter ]
-What is it called?
-Irlandsk julafton.
-Yes, tropsky lofften.
I like that you call it
"Irish Christmas Eve."
Now, you play this a lot
in Sweden?
-Yep.
-What do you do, exactly?
-So, um, here is how
the game works --
you place your forehead
on a bat.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you spin around
until you get really dizzy,
and walking around as if
you've had a few too many.
-That sounds fun.
I love this.
And you're married to
Michael Fassbender.
He's Irish.
Does he play this game, as well?
-No.
He doesn't know that
I've been playing
this game for years.
But after this,
I guess he will.
-Yeah. All right. In honor of
your movie "Tomb Raider,"
we're gonna put a twist
on this game.
We're gonna spin around, then
run to grab our bows and arrows
and shoot at those targets.
-I like that twist.
-Now, the big platter
is worth 1 point,
the dinner plate is 3,
the small plate is 5 points.
20 seconds per round,
we'll do three rounds.
Oh, man. First,
let's put on our safety glasses
-Safety first.
-'Cause safety is sexy. Yeah.
We'll spin around...
[ Laughter ]
We'll spin around
five times.
Is five --
that's the thing, right?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Oh, it needs to be even --
unless you don't
have a pair.
-No. I don't have a pair.
[ Cheering ]
I didn't wear my heels, yeah.
You're the best.
Sorry. Let's get 20 seconds
on the clock, okay?
I'll count our spins.
Are you ready for this?
-How -- how many?
Is it five, now?
-Five.
-Five. Okay.
-On your mark,
get set, go.
[ Cheering ]
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five.
Go.
-Aah!
Whoo!
♪♪
Whoo.
-Dude. Oh, my God.
[ Cheering ]
-Yeah!
♪♪
[ Buzzer sounds ]
Whoo!
-All right.
I'm supposed to like this game.
All right, here we go.
-Whoa.
-What'd you get?
Oh, you got the big one.
-Yeah. I got the big one.
All right, so, now,
we're gonna do fi--
I'm out of breath from spinning.
-Me, too.
-I really have to work out.
-I need to get back
to the gym now.
-Ready for this?
-Phew.
-Yeah, I'm ready.
-Five spins.
Round two.
Let's do this.
Go.
[ Cheering ]
One...
two...
three...
four...
five.
-Whoo!
-And go.
♪♪
-Whoo.
-Oh, my God.
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
-No!
♪♪
[ Buzzer sounds ]
-No!
Mine straight between
the 1 and the 5.
-You should get
bonus points for that.
All right.
Do we have a bucket
in case I throw up?
Perfect.
All right, let's do...
-Whoo.
-[ Pants ]
-Wow.
-Grandpa needs
a time out.
[ Laughter ]
Let's do one more...round.
For this final round...
is this right?
-No believe will believe
that I was that fit, for the...
-Yeah, sure they will.
We're gonna spin 10 times
on this one.
-10?
All right.
-Yeah.
Here we go.
It's 5 to 1.
I got the lead on this one.
All right, here we go.
Oh, man.
All right, let's do this.
Ready?
-Yep.
-Go.
One...
two...
three...
four...
five...
six...
seven...
eight...
nine...
ten.
Go.
♪♪
-Whoa!
Oh, my Lord.
♪♪
[ Buzzer sounds ]
[ Alicia Laughs ]
-Oh, God.
[ Cheering ]
We didn't hit anything.
[ Laughs ]
Whoa!
-Whoa. That was fun.
-Alicia Vikander, everybody,
right there --
the real champ.